Speaker 1: Let's keep it going and speak
to more people, we've spoken to a number
of really interesting folks already
today. Let's go to why don't we go to
Enrique from Los Angeles,
California, the City of Angels.
Oh, David, you hear me, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Great cold. Or else, yeah, I just
wanted to say that what's going on in Ukraine is
really sad. It's horrible, and I really think that
I think that the world I just don't see how Putin
is going to stop what he's doing. I think that
he's crazy, he's a lunatic and that he really
that I don't see how inevitably in the future,
like we don't go to war with him. I don't know.
It's just pretty scary. I think he's going to hold
the country hostage with his nukes,
like he's going to threaten to use
them or he might even use them. I
don't know. I think he's desperate.
And it's yeah, I
Speaker 1: mean, I think you're you're
correctly identifying that Putin's personality
does not make him suited to just kind of say, OK,
you know what? You guys are right, we're going to
back off. It seems as though he needs either some
negotiated off ramp that allows him to save face
and at least come off like maybe he kind of won
or he's going to go down with the ship, you know,
and that would be nuke usage escalation of some
other kind. I basically agree with you about the
general concept here, which is Putin's not suited
to just say, let's quietly end this.
Speaker 3: Yeah, and then again,
like I've said before, like, how are the
difference between Republicans and Democrats?
Donald Trump got impeached over that phone
call with Zilin with the president of Ukraine,
right? Mm hmm. He was toying with them. He
didn't want to help them. He wanted to get
us out of me, you know, he wanted to weaken it.
How are they not using this? You know what I mean?
Why are they not putting it out there? Trump
literally was praising Putin in the beginning
of his campaign. Hey, Russia, if you're listening,
the emails help me blah blah blah. Paul Manafort
working for him for free. All of these
things regarding Russia, it's like right
there. Listen, we've been trying.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's just, you know,
Fox isn't going to talk about that. But yeah,
of course, it's like Trump is now taking
credit for arming Ukraine when he delayed giving
them those arms because he wanted dirt on Biden,
but ultimately was sort of shamed into releasing
the aid. We're trying to talk about it,
but you're completely right. It's not becoming the
predominant story about what's happening there.
Speaker 3: Yeah, man, it's just it's I am
actually I'm just really worried that it's a
really nasty situation and yeah, it's
Speaker 1: hard to imagine it ending
in any way that we would call positive.
You know, I think it's going to end in
in a destructive way, one way or the other.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, they need just Putin
just wants to rebuild the USSR. I mean, there's
no doubt about it. Yeah. You know, he's just like
Trump, ego. It's all about him. He's he's crazy.
I mean, the world doesn't want this anymore.
The world is too civilized now, I think. And you
know, I don't think even China wants to, you know,
reverse back to this type of of conflicts in the
war. You know, they want progress. They want to,
you know, I don't know, this is just
really bad. And I hope I think God
Biden is president. I mean, can you imagine
Speaker 1: imagine if it was Trump? I know,
Speaker 3: I know it would be.
And then Fox would be defending.
Speaker 1: It would be crazy. It would be crazy.
Speaker 3: Mean, we should really call it even.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Everything is good in L.A..
Speaker 3: Well, gas is horrible. I am
a truck, I have a I have box trucks,
I have a tiny little family business. And over
the last, you know, we were paying about $4 for
the diesel like a year and a half ago. Yeah,
right now my diesel is six something. Six,
I took gas yesterday. It's just
Speaker 1: so fuel.
Your fuel costs are essentially up 50 percent.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's it's it's I don't think it's
insane, like we go to I go to court, I live near
a Costco here. Hmm. I love Costco and their gas
is way cheaper. Right. So I've been putting gas
there for a long time and the lines are long.
Yeah. Right now, even if you get there at 5:30 in
the morning when they open up the gas at Costco,
the line is around the corner of the block of
Costco. Well, it's just it's just so bad. I mean,
yeah, it's really expensive here. But you know, we
got to do what we got to do and we got to support
Biden. And hopefully this works out well.
Speaker 1: Now let me ask you just one other
question do you pass along the increased
cost? I don't know what you do with the
trucks. I don't know if it's deliveries or
Speaker 3: what it will look different to
Amazon's Oh OK, deliver for clients. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, so do you pass along the
increased gas price to your customers
or do you just have to eat it?
Speaker 3: The trucking industry has become really
extremely lucrative when COVID hit, it just blew
up. You know, the people at the ports like I know
all about the stuff, the truckers, the brokers,
they're pretty much price gouging clients. And
it's this whole thing. Since China is now able to
pretty much China can people and China can sit
in offices and act like they have companies
here in the U.S., right? They are making a lot of
money. In other words, like the client I have now,
he not, he's he's Chinese born, but he was raised
here in the U.S. he has an Amazon business,
and he grew. He blew up. He's the millionaire now.
Speaker 1: So it sounds like what you're saying
if I read between the lines is you're already
charging enough that the gas cost is annoying,
but it's not going to break you.
Speaker 3: No, I'm not because I'm a
small company. OK. The bigger companies, since
they have the leverage in all the trucks and
everything with the ports, they're price
gouging. These guys and my I just did raise my
price 40 bucks per trip, OK? But it's
going to have to go up more. So yeah,
it is. It is, but it's going to
end up in line with the consumer
anyway. So we'll see what happens.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend,
we'll keep. Keep it up. All right.
Speaker 3: Thanks. Thanks,
man. OK. I love your show. You're the best.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Take care. There's
Enrique from Los Angeles running a
trucking business, a trucking business.